the students say and so they returned to
class on wednesday amid a wave
of increases in cases in kobe how
are you greetings cristian cásseres I tell you
that the school district asks
parents that if their children are
sick please stay in  In
addition, strict cleaning protocols will be carried out in their homes
to
keep everyone safe. It is worth mentioning
that the workforce must be
vaccinated, but students must not
comply with this requirement.
As of Wednesday,
the Southern Nevada Health District extends the
hours of  the clinics located in the
different schools the
screening tests and vaccines will be available
at these sites from Monday to Thursday
between 9 in the morning and 4 in the afternoon
in all the Cíes campuses in here in
the valley and the health district  It
also partnered with different clinics and
laboratories around the valley to
facilitate access to a vaccine against
the virus or a screening test.  ction
just visit the district's online page
and you'll have the option to choose
your preferred clinic
after job
airén president will attend former senator
habibir's funeral on Saturday inside the smith
center this will be his first visit since
he took  in charge as president, the
ceremony will only be for family and
friends. We invite you to follow the
coverage on our social networks and we
continue with the sunny days for
the first week of the year, as we can
see we will have
pleasant temperatures and reaching 60 degrees and
it will continue like this for  the rest of the week
I am cristian cásseres with his brief
informative of Spanish edition good day